how're you feeling today miles I'm great
how are you doing I'm doing spectacular
let me get the question out of the way
how's the knee the knee is fine I have
no issues with it so yeah I'm not
worried about it at all I'm just focused
on getting in shape right now honestly
all right but why are we hearing these
reports about your knee is a time bomb
and everybody's everybody's nervous
about some have taken you off their
draft boards how did it get out to this
this degree yeah I mean I honestly don't
know where these reports are coming from
me personally as far as my knee goes is
absolutely fine I've been working out
for teams I think you guys have seen the
videos and stuff so am i and
everything's fine
I don't know if this is a smoke screen
or whatever it is but you know at the
end of the day whoever wants to take me
would take me so I'm not worried about
it
what position are you expecting to play
I want to play linebacker but size-wise
are you a rush linebacker I mean it's
like your size is not I don't know is
that typical of an NFL linebacker as far
as a respek are off the ball very well I
know they're different but are you are
you expecting to be a rush linebacker I
would definitely consider myself an
off-the-wall wrecker
what's the difference um the difference
obviously being a rush back of you're
more on the edge you know you're
fighting with tight ends and tackles
more where as opposed to being off the
ball kind of more like a Bobby Wagner
world where you're kind of you know the
general of the defense yet we're
uncovering he does move around from
sideline to sideline I think that best
suits me do you want to play offense at
all you don't want to play offense at
all I think it would be fun to but um
Rivia Mike just coming into the league I
really just want to maximize my craft
and uh at whatever position they put me
I was hopefully linebacker octobot
linebacker so that's kind of what I'll
focus on but that would definitely be
cool to do that who did you grow up
rooting for my team
um I was kind of a bandwagon fan so as a
kid I just kind of lose height so really
kind of one of my favorite things all
times as the Rams marched [ __ ] Kurt
Warner that's kind of like one of my
favorite teams of all time have you
interviewed with the Rams at the combine
I did but I haven't had any business
with them anything who do you think's in
love with you who thinks alone with me I
don't know you know this is kind of a
it's kind of a dating game with this
whole draft and star elite you really
never know like one team's we show a lot
of engines one team couldn't show any
interest very very interested in you so
you really don't know man this whole
thing is it's crazy
yeah but you read okay you can't help
but have somebody either tell you or you
look at these mock drafts right every
day it changes yeah right yeah yeah no
I'm getting texts from people who
definitely kind of keeping me as a date
on that but I got you looking at Dallas
it as high as number four I'll be
amazing I would love to play for America
sing have you interviewed with cherry
Jones I interviewed I have an interview
with Jerry Jones no but I interview with
that except they're at the comma yeah it
is crazy that you you don't know where
you're going to like draft night you're
not sure where you're next whatever
three four or five maybe your entire
career is going to be I mean that's
crazy yeah it's definitely I don't want
to say overwhelming but it kind of
creates an anxiety because you really
want to notice where you're going I
think at the end of the day we all just
want to play football just know where
your next home is gonna be so that's
kind of a distress that you have to deal
with
give me the quarterback that you can't
wait to get your hands on quarterback
that I can't wait to get my hands on um
I don't have one in particular you know
what I mean I just want to get out there
and just make em pay it would definitely
be cool to get my hands on all of them
so to say so I don't really have one in
particular
oh come on you have to say you'd like to
get Russell Wilson and/or
Brady would be pretty good come on I
mean you know it would definitely be
good you know laying on one of those
guys you know what I mean but just any
quarter break any quarter break what do
you think about Josh Rosen what I think
about John Rosen I think Josh Rosen will
be the I think it would definitely be a
top three pick whether he comes out of
junior senior he's a phenomenal player
very intelligent
I hate he'll be fine he'll be fine but
yeah Josh Rosen is the man he's
everything I was I was glad to play with
him were you able to hit him in practice
no no no no no that was day if you did
this with me get closer - he's miles
jack the former UCLA linebacker joining
us Dan Patrick show your favorite Jim
Mora story is what favor Jim Mora story
ah equal me on the spot let me pay kind
of one of the things I really admired of
them of course more was really high used
to kind of get out to the rim you know
what I mean like especially if he felt
like things weren't you know being
played out there I really admire that
how he stuck up for us you know I mean
he would take a penalty you know just to
kind of get the message across that he
he was back in his team up so I would be
appreciative that oh but I want a juicy
story that's not a good one no I'm not I
can't I can't put no have as long as he
stays on the team okay all right I like
that the craziest question you got when
you were interviewing with these teams
is what I didn't get anything extreme
you know what I mean I definitely got
hit with some curveballs kind of would
like some psychological tests like what
do you think when you get an apple and
banana like will come to my stuff like
that but I think it's miles what what do
you think when you get an apple and
banana together I said I don't know I
just said a fruit yes Wow did they ask
you dog or cat or any of that stuff
yeah there
she like likes eating egg what do you
think about what comes among easier
seater bag like stuff like that so weird
stuff like that and it's weird I know
you're you're doing stuff with speed
stick the deodorant like you get your
player in there yeah yeah so kind of
working with speed stakes they really
just focus on you know the moment also
feel kind of just getting ready in
preference for the draft and everything
just how you're gonna shake the
Commission his hand addressing the
mediator really just you know being
around your fans taking selfies with
them and everything so yeah you can
definitely catch with me and uh jaylen
Rams have been doing on species Twitter
and Instagram so that yeah definitely
definitely check that out okay but this
is what you do during the draft take off
your jacket and then show that you're
not sweating not pitting out yeah just
let them know that speed stick is
working look at me I'm not nervous if
they've got my bag okay how are you
going to the draft yeah I'll be there
I'll be there ACOG oh good awesome
hey good luck with the future they're
miles and thanks for joining us thank
you all right miles Jack for me UCLA
linebacker the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience